je crois vraiment qu'on a fait le bon
choix parce qu'une fois que l'activité
sera relancé dès je pense qu'on aurait
une vie très agréable ici
ouais je le pense aussi ces vieux ben
est partie avant du finalement c'est
votre métier l'hôtellerie
non moi je suis électricien je devais
envie de l'essayer un truc nouveau vous
comprenez puisque c'est
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup celle qui est tout au
bout quels numéros déjà natus alors je
l'avais l'indicé est spécial jeunesse
est là
[Musique]
la cause du décès est toujours inconnue
et à corcelles
c'était notre première cliente
[Musique]
les gars de la station-service m'ont dit
que vous avez quitté le modèle à toute
vitesse
ici tout le monde connaît tout le monde
voilà ce qu'est cette somme vous
c'est vous qui l'avez fait
si je fais quoi ces fruits qui l'avait
faire
vous étiez avec cette fille le soir où
elle est morte vous n'êtes plus dans mon
groupe ntm légalité et vous avez vu qui
sait peut-être pourquoi je surveillerai
d'autres modèles j'accumule dire c'est
considéré comme un crime devraient
peindre le matin à ce qu'il avait fait
si je sais fois qu'il avait fait
c'est fou qu'il avait fait
bon j'aurais vu quoi
vous avez vu quelque chose
[Musique]